Transcriptor: Karen Garza Guzman
Revisor: Alessandra Mantellini
¿Alguna vez han pensado
dónde terminan nuestros residuos?
Cuando yo saco la bolsita,
pues al final, ¿dónde termina?
Muchos me dirán: “No, pues se recicla”.
Otros me dirán: “No, pues...
o sea biodegradándose o algo así, ¿no?”
Y otros me dirán: “De plano,
no tengo ni idea y nunca he pensado
dónde terminan nuestros residuos”.
Adicionalmente, creo que todos
hemos visto estas imágenes donde...
vemos a la tortuga
con un popote en la nariz
o vemos imágenes
de la contaminación por plásticos
y para todos nosotros es súper indignante,
pero muchas veces no sabemos
si somos parte de eso
o si realmente estamos siendo
parte de la solución solución
o cómo estamos aportando a eso.
Como que a veces no nos queda claro
cuál es nuestro papel
dentro de esta contaminación.
Y les voy a contar una historia
aquí en México.
Hace más o menos como dos años
tuve la oportunidad
de visitar un pueblo mágico
y después de conocer el pueblo mágico,
les pregunté a las personas del gobierno:
“Oye, ¿y ustedes
dónde tiran sus residuos?”
Y ellos me dijeron: “En una barranca
desde hace 15 años”.
Y yo me quedé en shock.
¿Qué pasa? Ustedes me dirán:
“¿Qué tanto es el shock, Lisseth?”
Ustedes han levantado la bolsita donde
tiran los residuos, sobre todo orgánicos,
y va goteando, digamos,
un líquido que a veces huele feo.
Ese líquido se llama lixiviado
y ese líquido, muchas veces, como...
nadie nos prohíbe poder tirar una jeringa
o un pañal con hepatitis,
o algún cubrebocas contaminado
o unas pilas.
Nadie te dice: “No puedes tirar eso”.
Entonces estos lixiviados
pueden ser hasta tóxicos
porque no solamente están combinados,
digamos, con restos de comida, sino que...
sino que también pueden tener
otro tipo de materiales.
¿Cuál era el problema?
El problema es que al lado del criadero
habían unos cafetales
y el cafetalero
tenía demandado al gobierno
porque estos lixiviados no dejaban
que los cultivos siguieran creciendo.
Estos lixiviados, imaginémoslos
en miles y miles de litros,
ahora colándose por la tierra
y llegando a los cafetales.
Es impresionante, porque esta situación
no solamente está en este pueblo mágico.
de los más de dos mil lugares
de disposición que tenemos en México,
o más o menos como los dos mil municipios
que tenemos en México,
solo 173, solo 173
tienen el control de estos lixiviados.
Entonces, en la mayoría de nuestro país,
más de la mitad de nuestro país
pueden estar sucediendo
este tipo de cosas.
Realmente es indignante.
Otro dato súper, súper,
súper cañón es que en México
nosotros ya no podemos tirar...
en la Ciudad de México no tenemos
dónde tirar nuestros residuos
y los tenemos que mandar a otros estados
como Morelos y el Estado de México.
Y bueno, y ustedes dirán: “Bueno, pues,
¿de quién es la culpa?“, ¿no?
O sea, ¿de quién es la culpa de todo esto?
Sí, puede ser culpa del gobierno,
puede ser culpa del Estado,
puede ser culpa de las empresas,
pero también nosotros como consumidores.
Les voy a poner... les voy
a preguntar algo.
¿Qué tienen en común el presidente,
Madonna, mi ex y yo?
Pues que todos somos consumidores
y todos generamos residuos.
Yo creé Ecolana porque yo quiero ayudar
a los consumidores a reciclar.
Quiero ayudarlos a que dispongan
correctamente de sus residuos.
Y bueno, pues ahora les quiero
poner un ejercicio que...
que...
que necesito que cierren los ojos
para que podamos vivir esta experiencia.
Cierren los ojos y ahora imagínense
llegando a un supermercado.
Agarran ustedes su carrito vacío
y van por los pasillos
comprando algunas cosas
que les faltan en su casa.
Ya que compraron ciertas cosas,
van a la caja
y empiezan a pasar los productos.
Tit, tit, tit.
Esto es como suena la caja cada vez
que pasa un código de barras.
Ustedes pagan,
agarran su carrito
y, digamos, salen del supermercado.
Y ahora quiero que abran los ojos.
¿Qué ven en su carrito?
Y seguro van a decir: “Yo veo productos”.
Pero lo que yo veo son empaques.
Cada vez que un producto
pasa por un código de barras
significa que trae un empaque.
Entonces también seamos
conscientes de eso.
Seamos conscientes
que también nuestro consumo afecta
y al final,
¿dónde van a terminar estos residuos?
La verdad es que como consumidores
no lo tenemos fácil, o sea,
no nos dicen:
“Superbién, aquí me dieron instrucciones
de cómo yo puedo reciclar este empaque,
este empaque es de este plástico
versus este, que este es de otro”, etc.
No lo tenemos fácil, pero...
y la cosa es que no sabemos
por donde empezar.
Y también, ¿cuál es la mejor decisión?
Pues para, o sea, pues para...
para hacer algo,
para ser parte de la solución, etc.
Lo que sí es que podemos tener
tres acciones que seguramente
van a cambiar la situación.
La primera es revisa tu consumo.
Si no conoces tu consumo,
¿cómo vas a poder cambiar?
Y yo los invito a revisar empaques,
a revisar etiquetas, revisar ingredientes
y a tomar decisiones
mucho más informadas e inteligentes.
Desde ahí vamos a empezar.
La segunda es levanta la voz.
Y ustedes: “¿Cómo levanto la voz?”
Las redes sociales,
o sea, a mí, hasta yo las uso
para mandar memes
y para mandar fotos,
pero también usémoslas para comunicarnos
con nuestras marcas.
Seguramente hay un producto
que te gusta muchísimo
y dices: “Es que yo
no lo dejaré de consumir”,
pero para esto son las redes sociales.
Contacta a la marca
porque seguramente tiene una página,
una página web o seguramente tiene
una página de Facebook o Instagram.
Contáctalos y diles:
“Hola, yo soy fan de su producto,
pero la verdad es que no sé
dónde reciclar su empaque,
no sé dónde.... ”
Pregúntales todo lo que necesites.
Diles: “Realmente soy un consumidor fiel,
pero me interesa esto”.
Necesitamos que las empresas sepan
que los consumidores tienen este interés.
Lamentablemente, en Ecolana
nos hemos encontrado con empresas
que nos dicen: “¿Yo para qué hago
un programa de reciclaje
si para mis consumidores
ni siquiera es relevante
que el producto sea reciclable?”
Y realmente eso nos deja en shock.
Así que, como nuestra responsabilidad
como consumidores,
levantemos la voz
y hagámosles saber
a las marcas que nos importa.
Y como tres,
recuerda que tu dinero es acción.
Inviértelo en empresas
que buscan ser parte de la solución.
Así de fácil.
Y conozcamos y ejerzamos
este poder que tenemos como consumidores
para crear el futuro
en el que queremos vivir.
Gracias.